e
10 o'clock we'll open the work session
on a house bill
1583 and since Dr was so accommodating
yesterday we'll give you first
opportunity this
morning
and we have your hand up yes um good
morning uh members of the committee my
name is Keen M Wong tax policy council
with the Dr and good morning Lawrence
gyon Revenue council with the no
Hampshire Dr um so once again to
reiterate Dr doesn't have a position
it's neutral on on the bill on the
amendment um and um we went we read
through the amendment and came up with
uh some some observations in terms of
the administration of the uh the
amendment so we like to see clar
ification or even U Point certain um
potential um roadblocks that we could
see um in terms of the uh the the
administration of of the amendment and I
let um Lawrence um go through those
observations you do have them in front
of you so I'll try to go more high level
and not Point by point so you have so
I'm not wasting anybody's time here um
in regards to the adjustment of the
amount it in terms of How It's worded in
the new bill and with the amendment
a little concern uh
regarding the specific language as to
swept is going to fund 773 as opposed to
the swept is to be calculated to achieve
that Revenue amount so there's a number
of calculations that go into the
formulation of the tax rate that
achieves swept and so the deter that
calculation requires a fixed number to
be reached and so the language as
written creates a question of how that
is going to achieved whether the rate
would need to be a little more fluid in
order to achieve 773 or if the rate is
intended to reach that and that's what
the rate is set to be calculated for and
so it just creates a bit of a gray area
and possible challenges and issues down
the road uh paragraph two under the uh
under the bill also it's not in my our
notes there but it does potentially
create a distortive effect uh depending
on when warrants are issued warrants for
202 for this fiscal year were set last
fall and so uh the presumption is that
this amendment this bill would require
an amended warrant to be issued this
summer otherwise the December billing
which would true up to achieve that 773
will be extremely distortive and so
you're going to see a lopsided billing
effect and that Distortion continues in
the following paragraphs uh where the
rate that the amount that to be
collected is now a percentage b a
calculation based off of admr so you no
longer have a fixed amount and so
there's a potential for that warrant
billing to be distorted
again one of the other issues identified
that we identified as a potential
problem is there's no uh Clarity in
terms of the expectation for excess
swept in terms of collections there's
the assessed amount and then there's
what it actually ends up being collected
and historically those amounts are
generally pretty uh accurate is my
understanding but should there be a
shortfall or just a temporal shortfall
it uh clarity as to whether the
municipality is on the hook for that
access right out out the
gate sure thank you and thank you for
being here and for taking questions I'm
just trying to make sure I understand as
we go because two minutes later it may
be too late for me um so you are saying
that right now we set a swept rate but
we don't necessarily know how much the
time Town collects because the swept you
know the original calculation is just an
estimate and then we threw up to the
actuals right so so is that what we are
talking about here so the rate itself is
is Cal is set to calculate a certain
amount for the general assessment to be
at a certain amount right tax collection
efforts are performed by the
municipalities and so which may or may
not collect the same amount because of
many factors there a potential there may
be a shortfall there may be a temporal
there may be an appeal yeah and and so
there
that there's the possibility that a
municipality doesn't collect the full
swept amount in the time frame and are
they then on the hook for that okay so
your concern is if we expect the
municipality to collect x amount right
now if the municipality does not collect
quite that it's their problem because
they retain it so they deal with it
right but right now because we would be
expected to transfer it again if they
are under the estimates now do they owe
or do we recognize that's your question
and concern abolutely just making sure I
understand it thank
you if I could provide further Clarity
on that I'd be happy to answer a
question
[Laughter]
[Music]
sence
says
773 Statewide
based
not
773 can you can you
that that that is one of the items we
identified as of concern which is why
we'd ask for the original language to be
retained to set the the swept rate will
be calculated to assess an amount equal
to that's the original language that
that's a off the cuff I I don't have the
exact quote off hand but the bills uh
the statute original
language require Dr to set a rate to
calculate a swept amount of
the
and and and also just to add the the
amendment here um So currently as as the
law is working right now um the Dr is
suppos is T to calculate um a rate to
achieve a revenue amount for the swept
of 363 so the amendment here in fact
actually changes that language we're not
now calculating the way I see it we're
not calculating the swept amount the
revenue for the swep amount we're
calculating for the Statewide based
adequacy a to be paid um through a swep
tax um so it's it's right that's so
there's that change there just to
clarify that's correct
yeah turning to page two uh in regards
to the Appropriations cap uh Dr does
anticipate the this would require
considerable effort to calculate and set
as well as a question as to who is
calculating the percentage cap itself
whether that be the Dr the department of
Ed or some other body uh and a lot of
that calculation and cap percentage is
going to rely on information gathering
primarily uh falling on the shoulders of
the municipalities and their
reporting CH could I ask a question
please so you're saying that that's
going to fall in the backs of the
municipalities so is this going to be
another burden for them is it something
special they're going to have to do on
top of what they already do I would have
to defer to the municipalities in
answering that it would depend on their
information collection as it is and uh
there is already reporting to the Dr but
depending on how this cap is implemented
there is would be potential for
additional information so we don't know
correct thank
you doing a calculation all this is
saying is there might be additional
issues in that
calculation with all du respect I think
we have to wait and see what M
municipalities say they're all
different well uh that's a true
statement please continue oh can we get
get through it we're gonna we're going
to die on the vine here uh because we're
not going to solve all these tell me
what a is a critical issue that's going
to kill this amendment without critical
issue not this maybe this maybe that
maybe tell me the critical
issues that we need amendments on I
think the greatest uh requirement here
is Clarity in terms of timing and
responsibility uh regarding the
disallowance of Appropriations by Dr
requires reporting for the
municipalities sufficient enough for us
to allow to do so as well as guidance as
to how those disallowances are supposed
to be processed assuming that process
goes into to effect whether a general
operating budget is approved by the
municipal voters if it isn't by a 2third
vote uh which would be the majority
required to exceed the cap how or
disallowance is intended to be processed
to the extent their individual uh
Appropriations that are voted on in
excess of the cap is it a reverse order
Clarity in terms of how that process is
supposed to work uh would be crucial in
regards to that so uh Dr to the extent
that this cap is going be placed in into
effect and Appropriations would be
required uh Ru making ability may be
critical to our ability to properly
administer that cap um as well as
clarity as to whether the dr's uh
ability to create forms without going
through the jail car process for this
process is an exception uh a second
major issue of concern is to the extent
that the municipalities are on the hook
for excess or they choose not to remit
the excess the language of the amendment
and the statute currently used the term
taxpayer if municipalities are to be
termed as taxpayers that runs into
issues of Dr confidentiality
requirements and additional carve out
may be required as well as the ability
of Dr to enforce tax uh colle tax
collection efforts against the
municipality and Clarity around that
process and whether or not it is
available I think those would be the
crucial issues uh that we'd be seeking
Clarity on the the the uh effective date
of this is July 1 of
2024 and the first action from the Dr Dr
is January
1 with the invoices is that my that's my
understanding the question is it's six
months enough time to have rules and get
this
done the answer is maybe I know yes
because going through the jail card
process is as you may know um there's
the public hearing process and then
receiving comments and then addressing
public comments addressing OLS concerns
so it is at least six months to to go
through the uh the jail car process the
the ru making process okay
representative Heath thank you Mr
chair with this knowledge and with the
knowledge that we still have so many
questions about cooperatives um there's
a myriad of ISS issues with this
amendment I'd like to suggest that we
send the amendment to the subcommittee
we'll be working this summer um and then
we can a lot has to be done here and the
time frame is tight I just don't see how
we can go forward with such a
significant amendment that has such an
impact on our city and I never thought
I'd be saying this but I honestly have
to say that I'm feeling it's very unfair
for the we excess weep towns to Bear the
burden of having to raise the whole $91
million so I would like to make a motion
that we transfer this um we re refer
this amendment um to the subcomittee on
education
funding and if one of my colleagues
would have it a
second yes y thank you Mr chair um you
asked Dar to come up you know with the
one thing that's really the problem here
you know that we could focus on and what
I heard is that Dar basically said the
problem is throughout the entire
amendment that there's not one thing
that I mean he listed uh I don't know I
can't keep up I don't type that fast but
he list half a dozen things that needed
to be addressed so I don't think there
is one thing I think that there is a
complicated um Nest here that really
needs to be sorted out so I would
support that motion that we send it to
the subcommittee which has the the
knowledge of Education they have they
understand excess swept towns they
understand the poorer towns they
understand the consequences that
sometimes we've missed um and to send it
back to them for them to work on it
perhaps in conjunction with with people
with Finance because we can bring in our
own perspective for that but um I just
feel especially when we you asked for
one thing and he just started listing a
whole slew of things and I couldn't keep
up typing so I would support um
Representatives he's motion if you
please I'm not disagreeing but I don't
know if most of these are procedural
they're not about the concept they're
not killing the concept they're saying
this is very complicated it's going to
take a lot of work it's not that work's
not going to get done until there's
something to do nobody's going to solve
this problem until there's something to
do right now there's nothing to do if it
goes to subcommittee there's nothing to
do so nobody's going to solve the
problem oh so I I I don't I I agree with
you that this could be problematic but
if we don't try to do something
nothing's going to happen you started
this is something you know you did start
something you this is something and I
think this is something that we can send
to the subcommittee for them to start
working on because it's not just
procedural there are some policy
questions when you're talking about the
differences of poor communities and
wealthier communities um the common sent
is municipality on the hook or as a
taxpayer on the hook um these are things
that I think are better addressed
through the education committee but this
is something and there are things we
certainly I sure as heck support the
7,000 you know that and I think this is
a start this is something you can work
with they don't need to start with a
blank slate they can start with this
information this amendment and take
their knowledge around education and how
swept works and the differences between
the communities and work out some of
these issues I think that would be a
really good second step okay by a show
of hands how many people would like to
send this to the
subcommittee
each we've got an education one that I'm
on the one the one there's four all
those
who don't don't want to send this to the
subcommittee okay four to four motion
fails please
continue I I I believe I addressed your
last question of what the the key issue
that I I that we saw at the Dr okay uh I
can proceed through the document again
further but if there are any other
questions I think that may be more
productive since you already have the
document in front of you well you you
know my position it's my Amendment so
I'm I'm I'm loathed to say y nuts let's
don't do it it's too hard this is going
to be terrible to do this no doubt about
it because it's a new process we're
starting with the number up here and
then figuring out how to get there so
it's a a widely different approach as I
understand it
but okay Mary you're on a roll I'm
sorry this this amendment it
it limits local communities in terms of
how much they can spend on education and
then in order to increase they have to
have a 2third vote which is difficult
always at best there are so many things
in the amendment that we don't know I
think um representative cordelli when he
spoke about the cooperatives there are
just too many unknowns how it will
impact this fundamentally changes the
authority of public education from local
municipalities to the state in some
sense in part
yes in a big part and it really
limits so many steps that we've taken um
and then there are other issues I just I
just think it needs so much more work at
least we have to push out the date um
just based on what what gr is telling
us but
fundamentally we are changing the spirit
of public education in the state of New
Hampshire that's a big
statement I I guess you're going to be a
no
vote I think we're done uh quite
honestly I appreciate your the issues
you brought up and all include that in
the with the folder but
I'm I want to move ahead and i' like to
hear other testimony thank Youk thank
you for your
time I think they're
staying are you going to hang around for
a little while yeah okay
good make another bite at the
Apple
who yesterday had something to say that
didn't get to say it please
just
um my name is Mark takoto I'm the town
manager in Waterville Valley I'm also
the tax collector in Waterville Valley
and you just asked a question about the
procedure right and the six-month period
if you put this into effect for one July
2024 the school budget has already been
voted on in Waterville Valley it's
set the warrant as Dr indicated the
warrant for
that uh
budget has already been sent to the town
last
winter
and the tax
rate if if you have to go back in and
put in an amendment to the
warrant and the amount goes up that'll
be reflected on the October 24 tax
bill
and we
cannot in our July tax bill unless there
are Provisions for it we
cannot tax anything more than one/ half
of last year's tax bill so all of the
increase will hit in the December tax
bill and for our community and the other
53 donor communities that'll be a huge
impact whereas if you if you took the
same plan but made the effective date
next July then we could
adjust and we would be better prepared
because we'd have another town meeting
and another school district meeting to
to be able to take it into
consideration we've already made votes
we've already made
commitments in both the municipal and
the school budget um um without this
additional funding um so for these 53
communities it'll be very it'll be very
uh a lot to take on in one tax
bill I I'll respond with two different
thoughts
M the thought of it won't increase
taxes as far as the the carve out that
the state is going to say is now called
swept
so the tax bill for the the individual
property owner is going to stay the same
with that
topic however with the increased
adequacy
payments the the swep payment will be
greater than it has been right that
greater amount could be an increase in
taxes fore well
the again I can only speak to our
situation but going from 76 ,000 swept
that's what our current warrant is my
understanding that the warrant will go
up to something like
1.5 million okay but our revenues when
we set taxes in October if this goes
through our revenues from Raising that
1.5 million will only be
$300,000 in our
community okay so we will have to send a
check or checks equal to the 1.2
million to here to conquer to Dr however
it however it works out as the excess
swep but it will have to be
raised in the tax rate in October if the
effective date is 1 July
2024 I might be wrong on that but Dr can
correct me but that that's my
understanding is it would be in effect
for the October tax bill I would look to
Mickey or mark because we did talk about
this that's that's correct so it would
reflected that on tax bill you got to
come up to the
mic sorry so that is correct the um T
make this all effective fiscal year 25
July 1 24 um it would all be reflected
in the tax bill bills that go out um tax
rate seting uh setting season starts in
October um each town has a different
distribution schedule um but it would be
reflected their new tax bill would be
reflected um in that fall uh fall 24
payment um so that's when they would
start be collecting that but there's
this the difference between a fiscal
year and a a tax year there's this lag
so there's this mix match so they're
going to be collecting revenue for all
the first few months of fiscal year 25
based on the old swept so they're going
to short cash um when you look at the
whole scope of fiscal year 25 so they're
going to be in a cash crunch um to start
um they're going to have to according to
this amendment they're going to have to
make their first payment January 30% 30%
so they'll have to make a
30% essentially down payment for
February 1 yeah February 1 yeah yeah so
they'll have to make a a first payment
off the revenue they're collecting off
that new tax bill in the fall of 24
they'll make a first payment um then
they'll make their final payment
um uh after the tax cycle is ended um so
in March 31st it's an April 1 to March
31st tax okay so so yeah our first tax
bill our first tax bill is always
limited to exactly 1 half of the prior
Year's total tax bill so in our case we
can only send out a tax bill in July
that is
$65 in our case right so we're only
going to collect even if we collect
100% that's all we're going to collect
on is
$6.5 then if our tax rate does go up as
I testified Yesterday by
$2.33 that would be a change to say 14
or
$15 that we've only sent out a first
half bill of $6 on our taxpayers will
face a
$9 per thousand tax bill in December and
that's and and that's all going to hit
on that one tax bill and then we will
have to collect a minimum of our
operating budgets and the excess swep
because in February we will have to take
30% of the 1.2 million that we have to
send to Dr and we're we're going to have
to make that
$400,000 payment so just as a as a
practical matter if the date changes to
uh July 1 of 2025 what's the difference
the difference is the the budgets that
we have voted on at town meeting will
stay in effect the tax rate would be set
on those tax bills and the original
warrant of
76,000 and we'll and we'll collect you
know it'll go on the way that it has
been uh being done and then the excess
swep the the effective date then we will
we'll now have a year to plan to to do
that uh and if Dr if we can have some
mechanism where we could increase the
July Bill next year
to because we will know what the
actual uh what actual warrant is for
swept if we could get something either
regulatory or or in the legislation that
allows us to adjust the July
bill um for 2025 then we would be able
cash flow wise it would make it much
much better but make this read right now
and we did that you'd still be in the
same boat you're in right now we would
be in the same yeah in my ARG arguments
from yesterday still do not go away but
but it's the immediacy that is the
immediate problem the the issues that um
the folks from Dr just highlighted those
those sorts of things can be worked out
over a year
period rather than over the six-month
period the the six-month period has the
tax rate setting in the middle of it
we're we're going to actually set the
rates in
uh October early November so if the
effective date was changed to
2025 it be enough time to handle some of
the Dr issues and and some of the cash
flow issu well it would certainly make
it better it from our
procedurally uh for us yes okay yeah um
I think there's two issues going on
there's planning uh that you're hearing
the mun perspective from an EXs weap
Community um procedurally there's a
planning a planning concern that he just
uh just discussed
um but there's still always going to be
that deviation between fiscal year
versus tax year and so what he what uh
was just kind of thrown out there as an
idea is if there would be authority to
modify your tax bill outside of the tax
cycle is that correct yeah to to solve
that cash flow problem instead of
instead of having the Stagger of six
months under the old tax rate and then
six months under the new tax rate if you
could have full 12 months under the new
tax rate that would um uh solve
potentially some cash flow problems um
but we set tax rates once a year um so
there's that's right yeah and and so the
first bill that we send out is only an
estimate and it's always based we're
still going to have a low First Billing
but at least we know it's coming and if
Authority can be given to the towns to
modify that first half bill in 2025 then
procedurally it it helps us so there's
this would would require an amendment to
change the date and to put language in
about being able to collect along with
all I shared a lot of the concerns that
the folks from Dr highlighted to you in
in the actual mechanism and the
collections and who's going to be
responsible for what I think you still
have to answer those questions and I I
do think that that's going to take
longer than six months I to answer those
I think those questions get answered to
the next budget cycle
yes just a very quick note um towns are
supposed are encouraged to have a
reserve to cover such unanticipated
things but I want to make it clear that
that is a guidance and advice and it's
not required and for example the town of
wiam is kind of an outlier because they
essentially don't have one we've been
floating on a 300,000 Reserve instead of
the you know 5 to8 or whatever the range
is suggested by the Dr so we've actually
started encountering some cash flow
issues because of that and this would
put a lot of pressures on the towns that
may not have been able to have a large
cash reserves because also sitting on a
cash Reserve can be considered you know
just taking taxpayers money and keeping
it in an account with no interest and uh
not very you know careful you know not
very easy to plan for so I just want to
emphasize that these difficulties are
very real and the weeds when we talk
about tax race setting and collecting
matter immensely because there is a huge
amount of confusion if the guidance is
unclear and it's it's a very complicated
process and I think we need to get it
right to provide the clarity and the
structure that people need to do their
jobs and it will take a lot of work I
have no problem Chang in the effective
date but I don't know that we're going
to be able to solve all the
problems now I mean well and and that
that would be my major concern is the
impa and I actually think that this may
impact the receiver communities as well
because as you take the amount per pupil
up if they have to remit that money to
the school district an a larger amount
of money those payments are set between
the school district and the town and you
may have the same types of cash flow
issues even in the re receiver
communities because of the large
increase in the total that will be due
to the school so I agree with you but I
don't know that we can solve that one
well because we can't but again if if it
is if it is eased by having some
planning time and some additional
Authority and I don't know exactly what
those changes would need to be but at
least we would have the year
knowing that it was coming forward but
okay I there's still a lot of other
issues to to deal with I to be sure y
okay I agree yeah we'll change the
effective
date and I don't know if we can solve
all the problems but just because what's
going to happen is this is now going to
be part of the next budget
cycle and a lot of the issues can be
addressed during that budget cycle I'm
talking about the state budget s
m okay Point well made
yes uh hello Zach Shen executive
director of the New Hampshire school
funding fairness project um just a few
points that I didn't make yesterday was
kind of rushing through towards the end
of the public hearing so I appreciate
the opportunity to speak again um I
think
I just a point that I I made I think in
the email I sent to division 2 after the
amendment was produced I just kind of
wanted to highlight again um
was I think this discussion has brought
up a bunch of those pieces I really
appreciate your stance of if there's
nothing to work on then work won't get
done right if if there's a balance there
right if if you it was too complicated
and you study it then how much pressure
is there to work on it but it is
complicated and so where's the push and
pull and the timing and the ability of
of different staff members to work those
problems out the one other element I
want to kind of add in there is and I I
you know we're an advocacy organization
so take this or leave this kind of from
our perspective but is the the elements
of this what do changing different
pieces do to the possibility of the bill
passing along the process um so and
please correct me if I'm misstating the
coalition's stance on this but for
example I think if you changed all of
the Dr elements they were just talking
about and that Mark just highlighted
from his expertise if it had the excess
sweat piece in it they would still be
totally opposed to the amendment is that
a correct statement okay and so not that
they have the say over the legislative
process just like we don't have the say
we might be on different sides on this
but are there elements that could be in
this amendment such as changing the tax
Authority that they were just discussing
to be able to you know tax outside of
the normal year that gets a little above
my understanding if that's going to be a
hang up in potentially addressing swept
and excess swept but that hang up in of
itself would not have an impact if it
was divorced from say remitting excess
swept that could be something to add
into the amendment to get that piece
worked out have Dr go through whatever
rul making process over the next six
months so that that layer at least the
logistics of that are set for the next
budget cycle so in that budget cycle
maybe we're talking about what does
remitting excess swept look like now we
can do it in a way that doesn't have all
these barriers now the conversation is
do we do it how do we do it as opposed
to how do we do ating excess swept also
there's all these logistical elements to
it yeah but I think your comment was
even if we fix it all you're still not
in favor of it not in favor of remitting
excess so well okay I'm from Hampton
we're
either so I just wanted to point that
out that relative to getting this buil
through the remain you know continuing
along the process that given the vote on
HB 1686 back in February that was just
about largely just about remitting
excess swept and how that was
killed does that change the the passage
potential potential of this bill and
would there be logistical and Rule
making elements to tackle now that then
could set up a more fruitful
conversation in January for the next
budget if that was the
objective part of this is to is to come
in line with the ports Direction and if
you take the excess swep out of this
then you've not followed the conval
Judgment conval says XX weeps goes to
the educational trust fund and that's
what this and that's what this does so
that I appreciate the excess swep issue
because I'm an excess swep Town correct
but at the same time the objective here
was to try to resolve the outstanding
issue of of the Judgment yeah and as an
organization that you know generally is
in favor of those rulings and and I
absolutely appreciate that the one
caveat I would put in there I think I
put in my testimony yesterday was I
don't know that increasing base adequacy
while also having the school spending
cap
would I don't think that that I'm not a
lawyer but I don't think that that meets
the conval argument because the basis of
the conval argument was we're not
receiving enough money from the state
here's why but if conval a school
district gets $5 million from this
amendment but can only increase their
budget by one because of the spending
increase does that meet the kind
of fundamental piece of the lawsuit
saying we need additional funds from the
state for Education no so I don't know
that it would satisfy the ruling I guess
is my point well it would satisfy the
ruling how it's funded is what is the
issue because it is funded out of out of
local taxes $400 million out of the 2.2
billion that's currently collected
locally would be reclassified as swept
so according to the judge saying we've
gotta you got to spend that much for
student it's
happening yeah I I see where you're
coming from I just um I don't know if
there's a way to get an opinion from
someone who is a lawyer on what that
would do to the case but that's what
we're here for yeah okay Mar you
obviously got something to say because I
can see you jumping over there I I what
I really would like to hear from is the
municipal Association we heard a lot
from the Dr and I I don't want to put
you on a
spot but but
but it but and in terms of what Zach is
saying to us fundamentally we need
another funding source we can't continue
to pay for Education off the backs of
our property taxpayers it's time that we
face that issue and figure it out we
need another source of Revenue I think
it's that simple that's why I think we
should refer this to the special
committee for education and start
talking about where are we going to get
extra revenue for
education enough sorry okay Municipal
Association thank you thank
you good good morning members of the
committee it's okay thank you very much
my name is Katherine heck and I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and we are here following
this legislation as school funding is an
important piece obviously to the overall
budgeting process and Taxation process
here in New Hampshire while we have no
position on these bills because again
they fall outside of the municipal realm
these are School related bills they
certainly do impact our members so
therefore we have decided to try to keep
a close eye on what's happening in light
of the two judgments that have occurred
and we sincerely appreciate the work
that has been done so far to try to
address the lawsuits as well as the
amendments that's come forward as I
understand that you are trying to be
responsive to um those judgments and
that is much appreciated as you've heard
from Dr several members and we have no
position between donor towns versus
non-donor towns because we don't get in
a position of pitting Town against town
so we won't weigh in on that section
because of course our members are
impacted differently um I think all the
solutions as we can see from testimony
and from the amendments are extremely
complicated and there does not seem to
be a clear path forward um that doesn't
have some unintended consequence so
while you continue to deliberate and
debate um the different options that are
presented to you we just ask that you
you know consider all the unintended
consequences as you've mentioned you're
not sure that you can solve for all of
the all of the issues isues um at hand I
would say that as far as the the tax cap
piece of the bill that particularly
caught our interest because that's
something that um local control you know
we do believe firmly in local control
and we're not really sure how that piece
directly fits into those judgments
however again we are we don't take a
position necessarily on education
funding but it does affect our members
typically on the municipal side a bu a
municipal budget
is about estimated 24 to 36% of a tax
bill well maybe up to 8 to 10% could be
the county up to and the rest being the
school budget right so that's very
typical Nationwide for that to be the
case um so of course Municipal budgets
are looked at very carefully in light of
other school spending because we have
the same tax base right it's the same
taxpayer paying over all of the funds
the local school the swept the county
and Municipal budget so again we follow
this very closely and we try to work
closely with our school Partners to
understand what their budgeting needs
are when we bring forward our Municipal
budgets understanding that there is
fiscal capacity issues especially in
some of um our e more economically
challenged communities There's real
fiscal capacity concerns for them so I'm
not really sure what questions I can
answer um directly for you we just
wanted to say that we do appreciate the
work questions and answers I know and I
but I do we do appreciate all the work
that's being done around this because
this is a really important issue so
thank you for being responsive um to
that yes thank you Mr chair thank you
for coming testifying and for taking
questions you were referring to a you
know typical uh breakdown between County
and Municipal and the school budget what
would you say the you know typical
percentages would be just ballpark I
know they from town to town but you said
typical and I wasn't sure what the
typical values were so again it it is
going to vary wildly depending on
community but generally it's not
uncommon for 60% of the budget to be the
the school and that's again Nationwide
that's very typical um because it's such
a heavily service-based salary based um
delivery Educational Services where the
municipal budget would be that less than
30 and here in New England and
especially New Hampshire our counties
not to say they don't do very important
work but they don't do the same type of
work at that they do out west so they
typically have a smaller slice of that
piece of the pie thank you just was
curious I appreciate
it yes question thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question I think
this should be an easy one for you um
even though you've said that you don't
want to take a position on the bill
itself or the underlying Amendment
um is it safe to say that if this
amendment were to impose an additional
additional administrative burden of
collecting and remitting taxes on a
municipality that previously did not
have that
responsibility uh would those same
communities prefer to be compensated for
that additional
work so that is a very good question and
we have seen several bills that have
this session and the session before that
we have had to weigh in on that look at
remitting swept for example to the state
or on a different schedule all swept so
we're just going to pull that piece out
so the municipalities collect the taxes
on behalf of the county and the school
we perfect the tax collection system in
that we owe 100% of Our obligation based
on the schedule dictated by law or by
the local school board so the counties
um it's right in statute when we must
pay over in December whether we've
collected it or not as well as to the
school we pay $1 % of the obligation
it's not uncommon for a community to
have about a 3% uncollected tax rate it
could go much higher depending on
certain economic certain circumstances
in that community at the time perhaps
fiscal stress could play a role in that
but just imagine a world where 95% of
the taxes are collected but you owe 100%
to all your vendors everyone you do
business with as well as the the county
and the school district so when some
bills have come forward to have swept be
collected and remitted on say December
15th I may or may not have those dollars
my tax bill may be due before then but
it certainly can't be due before
December 1st based on our tax rate
setting process it may be due December
31st so I have to pay money over whether
I have collected it or not so there's
not only an administrative piece to that
but there's a cash flow concern about we
would have to take out costly tan notes
tax and anticipation notes in order to
meet those obligations so again we do
have a very efficient system here in New
Hampshire we have very um clear taxation
formulas here in New Hampshire we have
excellent Tax Collectors this is not to
say that everyone's not doing an
excellent job but the system itself we
have to just be again those unintended
consequences on any administrative
burden would fall on the municipal side
because the school has nothing to do
with the tax collection process the lean
or or the deed process by Design right
it does make for many efficiencies that
we don't have multiple people collecting
taxes which is the case in other states
and everyone kind of has a piece of the
pie and that does dilute um and make
things a little more complicated
depending on which Bill wasn't paid so
there is that consideration of course
administratively and the timing of that
um remittance back up to the state
whether or not we've have collected it
and is there consideration for
uncollected dollars because when you
send over your tax bill you don't get to
determine the $100 I want you to apply
to the school and 50 here and I'll come
up with a payment plan because you know
I've had some rough times maybe I've
lost my job it it really doesn't quite
work that way because the obligation
side is determined Again by Statute by
right by the local school board and we
have to spend and pay over on their
schedule based on their cash flow needs
um okay let me let me just make a a a
a strategic
comment my intention is to amend this to
the extent that anybody else has other
suggestions that make a lot of sense and
to move it out of the subcommittee into
full Finance it could very well die
there the underlying bill will not 18 uh
1583 will still move
forward uh but we're going to have to
vote we do we have to vote that out of
here 1583 the basic we got so H hung up
on the amendment I don't even know where
we are we we've taken no votes on 1583
so depending on what you decide to do
with this amendment you'd still have to
make a recommendation on 1583 so because
I want 1583 to move forward regardless
uh all right
uh well do you want to make a motion on
1583 and just get that off the table
I am I done hey I mean just in
discussing the
motion if we move
1583 how will then we continue to work
on the amendment you know never mind I
mean good idea I I think that the intent
obviously we have all heard that we
intend to move 1583 forward but until we
have an amendment decision probably by
the full finance committee you know no I
think we have to make a recommendation
on both yes right but but they need to
go in the sequence of the am Amendment
first and then correct and I would argue
that while we would not probably be able
to we would only be able to vote on 1583
amend as amended if we agree to the
amendment but while we can only vote it
that way I think the fact that we are
all agreeing that 1583 if unamended is
still a you know recommended bill should
take care of any issues in the full
finance committee so I would suggest we
work on the amendment first once we have
a decision on the amendment we can vote
on 1583 if amended and then take it to
the full Finance but full Finance still
has to vote on on both of separately
correct right which is why I'm saying we
we'll will retain all the options in
finance but here I would argue that we
should deal with the amendment first yes
thank you we have someone who's worked
on budgets Mr Duan from New Market um
can we hear from him as well sure what
I'm looking for are things that need to
Bei to make this less unpalatable or
more palatable I'm not going to solve
all the issues we're not going to be
able to dot it cross every te and Dot
every eye I want death things and I
think the date effective date was a
death so are there other items in here
that are deaths sir yes hello uh my name
is Paul desan and I work for the town of
Newington uh but prior to that uh I was
the Town Administrator in stratum for 30
years um I'm uh also Vice chair of the
Coalition communities U uh to which mark
tooto spoke prior
um our fundamental issue as a coalition
is is is the excess swep uh Point um but
I think it goes to representative SE
argument that uh as long as we continue
to rely solely on the property tax we're
always going to have these complications
these complications these
complications um both from you know
administrative side of things with Dr uh
let alone how towns and cities managed
their cash flow uh how the school
districts managed their cash flow uh I
keep going back to u a statement made by
representative
Solsbury um on January 19th he said
fundamentally we got a situation where
the local tax is masquerading as a state
tax and we kind of want it to be both
things depending on where we sit and how
we justify things that to me
crystallized exactly what the issue is
Rel to school funding and continuing use
weep uh as the answer the be all the end
all and I think that's the fundamental
issue um in terms of putting it in
perspective for newington's uh situation
my prediction would be that um uh the
town of Newton just for an excess swep
as under present law um Our obligation
to the state would be
$784,900
um that's a additional money because now
we're giving it to the state uh as
excess that we would have to add to our
local tax rate so taxes are going to go
up uh for the property tax payer um you
then add the Rand decision and although
yes we're going to get a little more
money uh relative to uh the per pupil uh
expenditures for our school um with only
60 or you know the enrollment averag is
between 59 65 in in Newton uh very small
so that incremental addition is not
going to offset the tremendous increase
in the swep amount that you've just now
almost doubled U going from 41 to to the
7300 per per student so that plus the
excess is going to be a
3,179
641 obligation on the town of Newington
and that's not that's that that's if it
was occurring in
2023 2024 something similar 2025
something similar year after year after
year that adds up to a lot of cash and
one thing hasn't been stated uh I'll say
that from from a taxpayer
standpoint I live in the town of stratum
and we had a significant increase for
multiple reasons uh in our uh local
school rate and taxpayers were off the
wall because they weren't giving enough
communication that that was going to
happen so people who have mortgages and
they've escorted the amount they're
short this bill will only magnify that
uh circumstance so taxpayers will have
cash flow problems uh you know if you're
on a fixed income you usually put a
little aside trying to meet the tax bill
uh when it comes due again the surprise
and and I just don't know how you this
complicated a situation how you're going
to be able to effectively communicate
that the
taxpayers um so that they can be
prepared um haven't been in the the
public uh realm for for number of years
I know they're always someone who won't
listen to anything uh and then I shocked
and surprised but even those who spend
most of their time trying to be informed
were shocked and surprised when stratum
had this large increase uh so
so the fundamental issue and
complicating factor is Reliance on the
property tax be it a state property tax
uh or a a local property tax local or or
local taxpayers because from our
Viewpoint we send out the bills they
write the checks to the town of
Newington they have a problem with the
bill they go to the Newington tax
collector they want an abatement they go
to the Newton uh
selectman they make no recognition that
swep is a state tax you know you can
call it what it is as as the
representative sburg representative but
in their view it's a local tax and it
should be a local decisions relative to
the expenditure of those those taxes
adding the swep just moneyed the
waters and continues to do so and I'll
leave it at that okay did anybody else
have a death mail they'd like to
present because I'm primarily resolving
death nails at this point uh to see if
we can at least get it out of this
committee and it's a full
Finance well good we're out of death and
else
anyway just a question if I may Mr chair
um given that you are planning to have
an amendment am I correct to assume that
we will have to have another meeting on
the amendment in order to uh well we can
if if we can agree what the will vote on
this this amendment being amended and
then that will come to full Finance next
week I don't think we have to I don't
think we can turn it around in time to
have another meeting that's what we're
saying we're going to edit this one with
these changes and then we'll rely on the
changes we'll see them next
Tuesday I've actually found out other
committees do that we always had the the
guide that you had to see the actual
Amendment the other subdivision
subcommittees here uh do this and to see
the edits and they see it for the first
time in full Finance
so I'm rather than to come back another
time Mary do you have okay thank you Mr
Speaker I think while I'm speaking for
myself I would love to see a success
here and I mean everything that we're
hearing there are many problems here
that we are not going to be able to
solve and changing the date is going to
do very little to address those problems
I would really like to see
this move forward in a way where it
becomes a success um you seem to have a
strong feeling that this will get killed
in finance it probably will um pretty
darn sure it get killed on the floor
because as soon as you say your property
taxes are going up that's going to be
gone especially since if I may this is
an election year and a lot of those
people are going to be paying attention
to that I would like to see a success so
that was why I think the suggestion is
to take this and move it along to
education with Finance people and you're
on that makes sense because it gives a
chance to listen better more
deeply to a d or Dr No D Dr D you're not
that but the Dr I would like to see the
success I'd like to see a a program that
goes forward I think that having this
says yeah we care we want to do
something and I see it as a first step
towards that goal where we can have all
the participants and the municipalities
everyone coming in to say how are we
going to make this equ
I mean where it is right now um the
excess swep communities are going to
take a huge hit and the poor communities
are going to be locked into being a poor
Community forever in terms of their
education because of this CA and so
can't we move forward to say we want
this to be a success let's continue
working on it and move it away from the
bill let the bill go through we've got
time there has been the stay so it's not
like you know we have an April 1
deadline but because I want this
everyone is we all want to see a success
year we all want to see this change this
is an opportunity to say yes we all care
about it and let's continue working on
this we've got so many problems with it
now even the the technical stuff of the
D
ra um that's that's a big knot to untie
I mean for me it'd be a gordian knot but
working with them we can do that so
isn't there a way that we can take this
and say yes we care we want to have a
success and move it to the committee
with a bunch of us maybe we make the
committee a little bit larger uh we
involve all the stakeholders and turn
this into something we can work with and
be proud of just just minute Dan just so
you know my recommendation in that
committee was to have this bill go to to
Ways and
Means yeah I said this doesn't belong in
finance this is a ways and means issue
because we're not raising enough money
exactly they didn't listen so I'm
listening then you have a yes I um thank
you Mr chair I just wanted to state that
I agree with a lot of the concerns that
there is a lot of work to be done
obviously part of the technical and more
detailed fixes could be taken care of in
the next budget process because we all
know that whatever we may adopt today
will not make it through hb2 unscathed
right
but I would suggest that probably the
best way to go forward as far as I am
concerned is to see what the finance
committee as a whole has to say about it
because it is a complex issue as you
said really it's more of a ways and
means deal anyway but we are discussing
it here because uh you know it was
assigned here but I would feel
comfortable you know making a decision
on the amendment to send it to the
finance understanding fully that
whatever the finance decide that you
know depending on the debate I may
support the amended bill or not but I
think there is value in having a
discussion with a full finance committee
because while this this is our bail week
it is also a immensely complicated
process where everybody else on the
finance may have some valuable input you
know to add
so well I appreciate that and my my
question to the committee is I we've
identified two push points that we can
we can we could solve with a rewrite one
is the effective data and the other one
is to have language that allow tax
collection in advance in anticipation of
the effective date of of of the
legislation so Mr chair I haven't been
able to share my thoughts about the
amendment yet so um if you are accepting
other ideas for amendment to this
amendment my suggestion would to be to
stop after the Declaration of the
7300 as the amount for the new base
adequacy and then to move to the effect
acve
date because I'm saying everything in
the middle is so problematic that the
minor bandaids were suggesting to put on
this hemorrhaging amendment is not
enough to save the patient I think the
patient's going to go down and I think
we all recognize that so my you know if
the intent of this amendment is to go
forward I think much more work needs to
be done than what a piece of paper can
do in the next you know 72 hours so I
appre appreciate your um desire to move
forward with these ideas to meet this
obligation you know um of course I
applaud that effort um but what I would
say is that those rulings as we all know
as people who are aware you know one
ruling can be overturned with the next
so you know we are under a stay for one
of those rulings and we it's very likely
that there could be another stay for the
other ruling so um I do believe there is
time here to do the hard work and to
find a solution that will meet the
intent of both the rulings and our
desire to do something for the state I
think that if we try to Band-Aid this
amendment up it will just be
performative if this is a performative
politics move to say oh we're meeting
Our obligation of the rulings and look
at us in finance we're trying to solve
the problem no the what is going to
happen in the next week will not be
enough to solve the problem I you know
respectfully I don't believe that's
that's the case given the overwhelming
testimony yesterday and again today
there are significant unintended
consequences um and then just as an
aside um I think that
this amendment misses a it is lacking
creativity in terms of how to solve the
solution I think how to solve the
problem of you know swept how to solve
the problem of raising
adequacy the only solution
proposed in the amendment is to go at
swept to you know increase swept to
limit the cap in the future it's not to
expand the vision of where does our
state get you know the revenue sources
to feed school funding and I think if if
we really want to tackle the problem in
a way that does not put the full burden
on property owners in our state we need
to back up and look at all the other
Revenue sources and find a more diverse
ified way of existing tax revenues to
solve the problem in a way that's more
Equitable to people across the state so
for instance not just people who own the
land P pay to help fund our schools more
it's you know there's a whole population
of people who come and do business in
our state that could also be working
towards solving that solution
so um I think we have an opportunity I
think the Band-Aids proposed are not
going to solve it and I think if we do
do want to do the work if we do want to
address this we need to send it to the
subcommittee that is not only charged
with you know solving school funding
with a greater perspective but also to
to give them the room to do the process
to look at the process
and this I think if we were to try to
pass a this amendment it's going to
undercut the state's ability to address
the problem at a bigger from a bigger
perspective if you limit it to swap
you're just going to continue to push
down this alley that we all know is not
sustainable and if we're looking for a
sustainable long-term solution one that
is not just a two-year solution but one
that will last for many years for our
state we have to back up we have to
reassess the process and we have to do
the hard work which we are which we are
capable of doing but not in the next you
know four
days I appreciate your comments but
there are multiple Revenue sources that
go into
education and uh business profit tax uh
all the liquor uh commission profits go
in there uh part of part of the gaming
commission I mean there's multiple
multiple feeders into this so it's not
like yes but the only solution in this
amendment is to look at property tax
we're not we're not talking about
getting more Revenue into the education
trust fund right now I I agree with you
totally which is which is why I think
you know way means needs to weigh on
this weigh in on this I think they need
to have a say about where the education
trust fund
sourcing how much of that moves forward
well sounds like you have a bill for
next
turn Mr chair could I just add a couple
of things we haven't talked about Equity
we also haven't talked about what's in
this amendment that we're shifting
authority of
the running of Ed local education from
the locality from the local control of
school districts to set their own
budgets will now be a state run effort
um the the budgets will be set on a
three-year average by
Dr that takes away the local control
that has long been a history in our
state and equity and funding
for all kids is something that we've
talked
about forever and the commission that I
sat on um with representative Ames a big
part of that was about Equity so that
all children in New Hampshire are
getting at least close to the same kind
of education and this amendment doesn't
even direct that at all actually it goes
against that so I just had to mention
those couple of things thank you Mr
chair I reiterate my position I got you
I addressing the conval judgment and
trying to resolve
it uh all the other arguments are
absolutely correct but that's not what
what we're here what this committee is
here to do that's that's a bigger
discussion so I mean I don't think we're
could put an amendment on here to say
let's let's up this is prophit taxt
motion and that's ways
means yes d one last short question um
besides the fact that by the way local
control goes with uh you know your
ability to raise funds to run your town
if you are running your town based on
funds gathered by other people other
people have a say in your local control
because you're using their money so
local control works really well when you
are paying from your own Pockets when
you're paying from somebody else's
Pockets there is a degree of limitation
local control that comes with asking for
those funds so that's a very interesting
philosophical discussion way out of
bounds for today but my question is say
that we do not address the conval
judgment and that the Judgment does not
get State well how in God's name are we
going to deal with that or is that also
out of bounds for this particular work
meeting I because this affects my
decision on whether this amendment you
know should continue or not because part
of it is to frankly hedge against the
possible choice of the Judiciary to not
issue a stay and force us to start
paying you know in a week or two or
three just start disbursing money
outside of our normal process and with
huge impacts on both this year's budgets
and next year's budget process and
everything so I'm trying to understand
if we do not pass this what risks are we
taking in terms of the conval Judgment
not being state that I don't
know Mary can I move the uh Amendment um
the bill um can I out um
recommend House Bill
1583 are to
pass not until we have an
amendment we might as well vote we know
what the vote's going to be unless you
go get Ken it's going to be
44 that's why I'm going to take a five
minute
recess correction if you please this is
the Supreme Court issues a stay over the
sweeping conal school funding decision
there hasn't been one on Rand but I do
believe there's one on conal and we're
talking about conell here I appreciate
it that would
you
yep so we'll
take five minute break
yeah
down
e
we come back to order for the work
session on uh House Bill
Amendment uh what we've discussed is an
Chang the
amendment to an effective date of July 1
2025 and adding language that allows tax
to be collected in
anticipation of the of the
implementation because a calendar year
and a school year are not the same thing
so those will be taken care of by Mickey
and be that will be part of the
amendment as it appears in full
Finance so I would
move the amendment whatever number it
will be currently it's
105 with those two changes the date and
the tax collection in anticipation
edits uh has ought to pass
second any further
discussion okay well we'll do a show of
hands on on the amendment all those in
favor of UT to pass as amended raise
your
hand five all those
opposed
four
no the amendment Amendment I'm the
amendment as amended the amendment yeah
okay so the amendment is passed now the
question is uh the basic Bill
1583 do we have so move by okay Joe
move you allow the CL a moment oh okay
oh come on once we start rolling we
really
roll
ready
okay so representative pet3 moves 1583
as
amended and I'll second
it otpa well this this amendment we're
saying now applies full Finance has did
the same thing yeah this 1583 but not
well then that'll be a vote in full
Finance right so right now you can
oppose it now and then vote for it later
it's just a recommendation at this
point okay so we have a motion M second
to OTP 1583 as amended y I think we need
a roll this yeah then just give me one
moment to get to the right sheet
please
one more moment to get to the right
sheet never mind the right sheet the
clerk will call the
RO want me get I got it I'm good I'll
catch up on the paperwork Let's uh get
going okay so uh the clerk will call the
role chair emeric yes uh representative
Petri yes representative Bean yes the
clerk votes yes Representative buo no
representative Heath no Representative
muray no representative hacken Phillips
no represent chairman
Wier thank you the motion passes 5 to
four okay I will write it down thank be
recommended to full finances ought to
pass as
amended now we have another one hope
it's as much fun as that
one
uh this is we'll close the work session
on 1583 and open the work session on
1656 two different ones okay
thank
you if I do it side by side basically
your your amendment has higher dollar
values well and what can I speak I speak
absolutely so um this amendment number
um 132 7h is an adjustment of the
dollars based on our subcommittee um
representative luno um had called me and
asked me why the numbers were so low
because we had agreed in the
subcommittee that the amount of a
special ed Aid that would be within this
bill um
1656 would be $35
million and so it ended up being 17
million um as presented so we just
wanted to to make that adjustment so
that local school districts who we all
know are suffering from The High Cost of
special ed would get the full 35 million
that we spoke to as part of our agreed
upon we all agreed
subcommittee is everybody following this
because my I'm I'm trying to remember
what my amendment I think that was in
the original Bill wasn't it what did we
change so if you recall there was a uh
uh an issue raised over the data and
that there was a catchall a number of uh
kids that sped that didn't fall into
each of the categories so doe had
identified um a provision and you see
that on both amendments at the bottom
starting on line 14 excuse me it's 15
where any pupil receiving special
education services identified by the
department that was nut and the
Department's data collection efforts uh
shall default to category a so that's
the the technical fix that Doe had
brought forward last work session okay
so that was my Amendment yes and that is
also included in representative heaths
and the Really the difference between
the two is the per people eight amounts
in paragraph sub paragraph da a excuse
me D1 on line five and the cost
approximately uh yours representative
Emer is about $17.7 million in 25 and
representative Heath is 35 million so
that's materially the
difference and this is going to come out
of uh educational trust fund anyway and
there are sufficient funds right now in
the educational trust
fund I'll agree with you Mary because
you got me on this
one so would you like to would
you I'd like to Second
it that was great what are we moving
specifically uh
13 13
273 thank
you okay does anybody have any
discussion it's basically different
values and the addition of the
catchall so if
you're well
I uh for the uh Heath Amendment 1327 H
approximately $35 million and the Emer
Amendment uh1 12 11h is approximately
$17.7 million and and I will also just
remind the committee these are those are
numbers based on this bill isolated you
also are moving forward with 1583 which
makes other changes to the education
funding formula if you ultimately pass
both uh we would incorporate both and do
a number for you it might not be exactly
the sum of the two bills because there's
some Provisions that have some netting
uh specifically the hold Harless
provision uh just just throwing that out
there it's just be uh aware of that as
you move
forward I was going to ask you some
questions after this about what you
passed
out for which Bill 1583
yep I can do it as part of this once
once we go through with this I'll ask
the questions in public sure sure okay
so we have uh the the heath amendment
has been M motion has been made him
seconded so I guess we'll do it by a
show of hand since it's an it's an
amendment yeah we don't have to we can
do this by show hands okay all those in
favor of the heath Amendment raise your
hands okay all those in favor of the IMC
Amendment raise your
hands okay
so well technically this was a motion
just did not in favor of the heath
Amendment raise your hand sorry about
that now I would I would make a motion
uh for
my uh Amendment 1211
H and again ask for a show hands all
those in favor of my Amendment please
raise your
hand okay all those
opposed Okay so we're going to we're
going to go
with
1211 then we need a motion for
1656 as amended so
move I'll second
it and this is the case again where you
can say yay now and no
later
right so it has motion's been made and I
seconded it
for House Bill 1656 as
amended May thank you okay I will call
the all um chair americ
yes representative
Petri representative Bean
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Buco
no representative Heath no
representative
Murray representative hacken Phillips no
chairman wer yes the vote is 5 to4 for
the recommendation of otpa as amended by
11 sorry 211 1211 thank you Mary you can
bring this to full
Finance okay I guess that concludes the
formal portion but I would like to have
have some a question about the
handouts uh particularly this one that
you gave us yesterday through with the
kind of
summary I had a question that came up
about well does this include 1656 and I
think you already answered that it does
not okay and down at the bottom at the
net total net State cost do those
numbers are that neted out of the 90
million swept increase or is that that
accounts for the excess swept remitted
so this would be 110 million already
considering that excess sweps coming
coming in so the net increase on this is
1106 correct all right correct so we are
kind of turning into the Ways and Means
Committee we yeah because I think if you
do the math like the education trust
fund even though it's at a surplus of
like 200 at the end of the bium it's
going to be gone so now we're talking
about moving into the future you're
going to have to start bringing in more
Revenue it won't be gone to the take 100
million out each year it will be in two
years
yeah yeah well that
are well that's what the next budget
Cycle's
for and just a reminder that that $230
or so million dollar of education trust
fund Surplus that we refer to is the
projected Surplus at the end of this
bium y so we still have 15 months of
Revenue collections to get to that
number that need to come in on so that's
money that's not in the bank yet either
so that's just the plan at this point
well I'll be quite honest um
um my sense right now is that 15 the
amendment for this has little or no
chance of making out of Finance so this
is kind of a moot discussion so anyway
thank you for coming today and we'll see
I guess next Tuesday I we haven't seen
the the schedule yet we gener exact on
Tuesdays I would hope we'll also meet
tomorrow in session but yeah as a
committee right right as
yeah you had to remind me yeah tomorrow
no chance to do the and tomorrow night
it's look like another 8 o'clock look at
that you got got half an hour extra I
don't know what to do with myself I
thought we was going to get
out could have well that would have been
any fun come
on Mary I'll be honest with you I don't
remember the
amounts I don't remember I I don't
I'm not going to get
you
for